(upbeat music)
- Oh s****!
- I'm sorry.
(person grunts awkwardly)
(woman laughs)
- What?
- It's pretty annoying.
- No, you're lying.
- I'm just kidding.
(both laugh)
- All right, so my first secret, a secret
is that I'm actually a
homosexual or like bisexual,
I like girls and I like guys,
and it's like, I was just scared
to tell you, so that's it.
- You scared me with the first part of it,
but I don't have anything wrong with that.
- Okay, all right.
Like being, like, in society today,
you don't know how people
are going to react.
Like there's a lot of homophobic people,
so it's like, definitely it's good
that she is not mad about it
'cause that's something you
should obviously tell someone
off the bat, so yeah.
- [Interviewer] How do you
feel after hearing that?
- Not any different. I'm glad
that he trusts me with it.
- Do you wanna go first?
- No, you can go.
You can go first.
- I'll go first.
- Okay, I guess it's a funny one, I guess.
I'm sorry.
- Oh no.
- I really wish you would
just take a poop in my house.
- Oh my god.
- I wish you could just poop
in my house without feeling insecure.
- All right.
- You know what, honestly, I
get shy, everybody gets shy.
I mean, going out in public-
- I'm your girlfriend.
- We're not ready for that
yet, you know what I mean?
Like it's just, it's a
beautiful relationship.
It's better than this, you know,
think it was still behind closed doors.
So I guess it's my turn. Let's go.
Oh, you know what I want.
Same thing.
You know how you were so
shy to fart in front of me
trying to come at me.
What's up?
Girls don't fart.
We don't fart.
We poo.
- All right so girls don't poop either.
Oh my God.
(both laughing)
Honestly, I feel better.
I feel attack, low key, that's okay.
[Narrator] Question to ask a
couple like, how'd, you know,
that you wanted to be
with the other person?
- Oh my God. You know, it's weird.
I've never thought about
that question till now.
I think for me, it's
more like, I know, sorry.
I think for me,
it's just like her accepting
me as a person I'm gonna cry.
Cause I've been judged multiple
times in my life. And like,
I feel like for her, like she's
never judged me, you know?
And like, I've been
through a lot, you know,
in other relationships,
like I've been physically
abused and like for her to
actually like ask me about
it, not try to protect me,
you know?
Like I've never had someone
who's actually been wanting to
know is that I've never really had that.
Not even within a friend and
then like have that as a friend
and then turn into a
girlfriend. I think it's,
I'm very grateful, you know?
And I think that's when
they knew, I guess,
but I didn't mean to cry.
- A big Secret is that
sometimes I go out to eat,
like by myself.
- I'll see the bags every once in a while.
- I'll find them.
You're not slick.
- Well, you know,
just to have like that little
personal time real quick or
- That personal snack?
- Yeah.
- It's fine to enjoy a little, a little,
a little taco by yourself.
- Every once in a while, I guess.
[Narrator] How often do you do it?
(laughs)
- Once or twice a week. Yeah.
Yeah.
- Okay. Okay.
A little weekly thing.
- This is really silly, but
sometimes I get jealous.
Cause I feel like you're
better at animal crossing
than me.
(laughs)
- That is silly.
I am better than animal crossing you.
You're the first woman
I've been sure about.
- I mean it's not like, I didn't know it.
(both laugh)
Like I dunno.
I think I'm pretty cool.
So I can see why you'd be sure
about I'm sure about you too.
- Yeah. So like we talked about,
it's kind of hard to
have a secret, you know,
when you're married.
But the thing I thought of
saying was that in the beginning
of our relationship,
it was almost like so
intense to be believed in to,
to the level that you believed in me.
And especially on my creative journey,
like the ideas I had
and the projects I had,
it almost like frightened
me in the beginning,
but now I look at what we're
doing together and I'm just,
it's kind of overwhelming
sometimes to see how far we've
come.
I'm just really grateful that
you've encouraged me to be
brave.
I love you.
- Love you.
(both laugh)
- Okay, ne thing that
I've always kept to myself
is I think it's think
is funny how you're so
oblivious to doing like
the smallest things.
- Like how things just
go way over my head.
It keeps me entertained though.
(both laugh)
- What about me?
- About you?
- Yeah.
- It's so complicated for me
to figure out what you want me
to do just by the pitch
of how you go, "hm."
(makes noises)
Like you're just reaching
for something and I'm like,
what the, what are you looking at?
Well, what do you want
me to give you right now?
- It's pretty simple. You
know, you just got a line
of what I'm gonna reach for.
(laughs)
- It's got to get like
the measurement, right?
Of which way your fingers are pointing.
- You go for the the water
then you go for the soda
and then you go for like the
orange juice or something.
- It's usually always the last one.
- Yeah.
It's usually always the last one.
- You're right.
- But that's okay.
That's okay. We manage.
- Well good.
Fantastic.
You know what? I'm happy for you.
- So glad.
- All right.
- So great.
- Great.
- Awesome.
(both laugh)
- When I'm in the shower,
I feel like I have to over
scrub myself like three times
ever. I don't know.
I don't know if it's
like a tick or something.
- That's your secret?
- That's my secret.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Well,
my secret to you would probably
be when we're in the shower
and usually when you're
scrubbing your face,
that's when I'll pee in the shower.
- You do pee in the shower!
I knew it. I hate that.
I hate when he knows
I don't like when he pees in the shower.
[Narrator] Disgusting.
- But when she's washing her
face, her eyes are closed,
It smells like face wash.
It'll be harder for her to
detect that. So that's when I go,
that's when I go.
(laugher)
(unintelligible)
- There's a place for the shower,
there's a place for peeing.
So go to the toilet.
- Oh okay.
Thanks for sharing.
- No, okay, yeah. You're welcome.
I didn't want to give
that one away because
now she's onto me.
- Now I'm gonna get urinate smacked.
- She's gonna be peakin like
She's in washing her face.
I think that's enough.
I don't think I want to share anymore.
(laugher)
You got something better than that.
What else you got? Come on.
- I secretly eat three bananas a day.
Did you know that?
- I mean, yeah, no, I didn't know that.
So that explains why they're gone.
When we go to the grocery store
and they're all the bananas
are gone.
(both laugh)
Not enough for my smoothie.
- Okay.
You know, I hate when you,
- Oh!
Oh s****!
(laughter)
Hey.
- You need to clean up after the bathroom,
after you shave, you know,
there's hair everywhere.
- I try so hard to get hair.
- Like everywhere.
- I can't get every hair.
- And there'll be times I just cleaned
the bathroom and then I can
hear you in there shaving and I
get so pissed.
- Because knows there's
going to be hair in there.
- Is he really shaving after
I just cleaned the bathroom?
I try really hard to, I really
try hard to, to get the,
all the hairs. I really do try hard.
- It's ridiculous.
- I'll share one. I'll
share one more of like a,
not a hate thing,
but more of like a thing I
love about you is when I do a
load of laundry, I could always
count on them being folded.
Nice and neat and stacked up
like a stack of paper laundry.
- Sometimes I hate when you
do laundry because you leave
them in the basket.
I've never shared that with you.
Cause you always leave them in the basket.
And then what happens?
They get wrinkled for days.
- Because she has really good
folding skills. Like she
makes him like, even.
- I think that's an excuse.
Cause you don't want to fold.
- That's one thing I never
expressed that to you,
but I do love when you fold,
take care of the clothes.
- Well you're welcome.
- And fold them.
- You're very welcome.
I didn't know that.
I just assumed that you just
wanted me to do it cause you
don't want to.
- Well yeah, I do I do
because you do a good job
at folding the clothes.
(laughs)
- Anything else you want from us?
You've been taken out of this now.
We've been together since
middle school. So, yup
take advantage of us.
- I think we just have like little things,
but all the major things.
- Middle school. I met her. I
was 11. She was 12 and I'm 27.
She's 28 now. So this is
so we know each other.
We've spent a lot of time together.
- Hey everyone. Thank you for watching
another episode. Also, I
just got some new merch.
So I'm just going to model a
few of them for you guys real
quick.
(upbeat music)
(upbeat music continues)
That's it. Thank you guys for watching.
I'll link my shop in the description.
I love you all and I'll see you next time.
(upbeat music)